aujourd'hui je voulais m'adresser je
vais prendre la parole ou mal adressé
directement au président de la
république monsieur emmanuel macron
parce que j'ai certaines interrogations
mes frères et soeurs et moi concernant
la suspension des 84 habitudes et quatre
policiers qui ont tué notre père on
comprend toujours pas pourquoi ils n'ont
pas été suspendues et je voulais aussi
ajouté que nous prenons également
comprend pas pourquoi la techniques
d'interpellation qui est la clé
d'étranglement n'a toujours pas été
interdite car quand on a pu le constater
c'est ce qui a tué mon père car gendrey
une fracture du larynx et on aime
tentent à leur incompréhension
aujourd'hui on s'interroge on attend des
réponses
donc c'est pour ça que je voulais
m'arrêter je voulais m'adresser
directement à monsieur emmanuel macron
j'attends on attend tous une réponse
solennelle bien sûr une prise de parole
qui pourra tous nous mettre d'accord et
en même temps nous soulagé parce que
encore aujourd'hui depuis le 3 janvier
on est dans la tente et ça nous plaisent
énormément dans notre chagrin dans notre
peine et dans notre vie de tous les
jours on a un sentiment de peur
d'impunité on aimerait que ça cesse donc
on attend tous une réponse mes frères et
moi et soeurs mon grand père ma grand
mère ma tante ma mère qui aujourd'hui
est celle on peut plus vivre dans 7
intègre interrogations là donc voilà
j'attends tout simplement une réponse